we've gone from 100 miles an hour to
zero if we can't start reading again
money will run out British business is
at a standstill
the economic cost measured by our
absence from streets shops and offices
you're in a war against an invisible
enemy
it's just totally beyond anyone's
control revival depends on lifting the
lockdown within the age of social
distancing can Britain safely go back to
work construction is one of the few
industries that has kept working this
site in Gloucestershire building more
than 100 retirement apartments has been
operating rain or shine throughout but
social distancing has cut the workforce
to around 60% and force them to change
every aspect of the Working Day
traditionally this would be a two or
three line operation you'd get through
the room much faster much quicker but we
now have to do it safely with socialist
distancing people can only work together
if they're more than 2 metres apart and
even the canteen is used in shifts five
people at a time managing director Mark
wake Food believes his industry may have
lessons other sectors can learn from
that Kovac 19 will still exact a price
it's very difficult to cut your losses
and run in this industry I think some
companies will face insolvency I think I
can't see how companies that are already
on the edge are going to stay solvent
given some of the pressures are going to
come many companies are just beginning
to plan how they will reopen to staff
currently at home or on furlough
millions of people work indoors in
offices like this they'd normally be
more than 50 people working at these
desks the question now is how do they
get back to work safely
the answer is social distancing on a
scale modern workplaces are simply not
designed to accommodate these lines mark
out a 2-meter space that will have to be
around every single employee social
distancing means none of the desks in
this area can be used you can see the
problem
constrain physical space will mean fewer
staff on-site for months we will
definitely need to be looking at a phase
re-entry into the office for a number of
reasons reducing congestion in commuting
as well as reducing congestion and and
density within the offices the pandemic
struck entertainment and hospitality
hardest of all
Bloomsbury lanes bowling alley in
central London opened in the width of
the 7/7 bombings it's never had a hit of
business like this this might be the way
you actually do it you have one group
taking two lanes so you've got you
you've got your distance
John knows businesses like his may have
to wait until the outbreak is all but
eliminated he wants the employee
furloughs scheme extended and a v80 card
to keep the industry afloat I think it'd
be unfair if you have coffee shops
around the corner with 50 people queuing
outside and pubs or bowling alleys or
restaurants have to will kind of open
first they all have to have real massive
restrictions when they do you'll be at
50% of revenue if that I mean we know no
one knows how quickly the conference
will come back and people will want to
come out the michelin-starred pierre de
terre restaurant offers a more genteel
environment but the challenge is the
same so it could be between four and six
people looking after a moderately busy
restaurant all in that fear the demands
of social distancing are incompatible
with working life in a busy restaurant
and with business models based on table
plans that will have to be ripped up to
give customers the space they need it
really is a small restaurant but it can
have maybe 40 people on the ground floor
if we were only going to be doing 20 and
I'm paying the same rent it's going to
be tricky to see how the business will
make money how it will survive at
supermarkets we've adapted to social
distancing out of necessity now two
meter gaps and one-way shopping mark the
way out of lockdown for the high street
this is Regent Street home to some of
the biggest names in retail and it's
almost deserted when these shots do
reopen they're going to have to change
this may
for now at the end of browsing it also
poses fresh questions about the future
of shopping on the high street where
many are banking on offering customers
experiences which may be impossible with
social distancing independent shop
owners like Christina have no choice but
to adapt we allowed people to come in on
set times for browsing then we will have
also a booking system online where
people can work in order to try to try
clothes on many businesses are being
kept alive with taxpayer support but
what nobody knows is how we the
customers will react when the shackles
are released as quickly as possible they
will lead the way for us the rest of us
will follow on once the coast is clear
after six weeks have locked down we
could all do with a haircut but salon
owner James wonders whether he can
afford to wait without even a vague idea
of when customers may return it may make
more sense to close for good the
business model starts to break down you
can't pay the same amount of rent
business rates all of the debts that may
have been built up through this lockdown
period and so as a business owner you
start to look at that and you say well
is it worth it
the lock down required to save lives was
always intended to be temporary but the
change is required to lift it will
likely last far longer with devastating
economic consequences of their own
Paul Kelso sky news